[MUSIC]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Ken thanks a lot for for coming out here
we really appreciate it and
I know a lot of people are looking forward
to this.
Just to pick up on Gart's introduction you
know, you're one of
the few CEO's on Wall Street who's still
at the helm post the financial crisis.
In addition, it couldn't have been easy,
you know, just months after becoming CEO,
being hit with 9/11, and facing those
challenges.
Through all those, what have you learned
about leadership through crisis?
I know there lessons that are applicable
about, to day to day leadership?
>> Yeah, I think clearly my tenure has
been one where I've had to confront
some of the most challenging crisis that
we've seen in the last 100 years.
And one of the mottos that I follow
actually comes from Napoleon.
And it's frankly a motto that I think
about frequently, and
it's very simple but very hard to execute,
and
that is that the role of a leader is to
define reality and give hope.
And that's what I think about, frankly,
everyday, because if in
fact you wanna have an inspired workforce,
you have to,
in fact, make sure that people understand
that you're grounded in reality.
But then you have to give them the
strategies, the ideas, and
the values that give them reasons to be
hopeful.
And as we went through the 9/11 crisis,
certainly we went through
the crisis of the this downturn.
One of the things that I recognized is
that it was very,
very important, very quickly to analyze
and
then communicate what the reality of the
situation was.
And even if that meant that those facts
were harsh,
the organization needed to understand it,
investors need to understand that.
But second, very importantly, it was
critical to, in fact,
take what appeared to be a very confusing
situation and, and
it, this is not meant to overly simplify
problems.
But what I do believe is you've gotta give
people an organizing device.
And so in the case of the challenges of
2008 and 2009
I had a mantra that I really believe if
you asked almost any company in
around the world for us any employee, what
was the mantra?
What they would say is it's stay liquid,
cuz that was part of the reality.
Commercial markets were frozen,
the credit markets were frozen, I thought
our balance sheet was strong, but
I wanted to make people understand based
on what was happening in the financial
services marketplace was stay liquid, what
did that mean?
Stay profitable, and that was part of one
giving hope to the organization that
despite the fact that a number of
financial services companies were losing
money, we in fact had an opportunity to
distinguish ourselves.
If we could be consistently profitable
every quarter, which we were.
And the third, back to the hope was that
were still going to
selectively invest in growth.
And gave them very spec,
very specific examples of the areas that
we were going to invest in.
>> Just to follow, pick up on that.
How do you, in the midst of what looks
like a complete perfect storm,
get people inspired to drive for growth
and invest in that and take those risks?
>> I think part of what you have to do,
again, as you state what the reality is,
I'll give you some examples from our, from
our business.
You gotta give people some markers of, how
do they judge you making progress?
Because simply to go out to the
organization and say look, we're, we're
faced with an incredible crisis, one of
the worst financial crises in 100 years.
But trust me, I think I'm smart, I think
I'm energetic.
[LAUGH] We're gonna get throgh this.
Your gonna say, give me a break.
that's, that's not gonna work.
So what I tried to do is one, I said,
let's look at the history of our company.
American Express is 160 year old company.
I actually used a number of examples
through our history.
But in fact, was able to use some of the
examples from 9/11.
Because most investors had written us off
in a number of ways.
And I took 'em through, how we were able
to get through that.
But then I said, here are some markers
that we are going to use.
One is, are we going to be able to
maintain
the premium prices that we charge for our
card, and to our merchants?
Because, as you saw in the crisis with the
downturn, and
the precipitous drop in spending.
So in our case, from 2002 to 2007, we
averaged 16% growth in billings.
Which really lead the market and five
quarters into the,
five quarters in, or five months into the
downturn, we had declined in spending 16%.
16% negative growth in Billings.
People were saying where the bottom is
falling out,
credit losses were increasing.
So I said, one is, one what we want to
make sure is,
will customers pull their card out of
their wallet at the same time.
So what's the transaction level?
And frankly, part of the risk there, was
saying to people.
But that's part of the reality is,
here's how you can judge if we're gonna
have success or failure.
So, people are pulling their card out of
their wallet.
At basically the same rate that they did
pre-downturn.
And that should give you confidence in the
future.
So even though billings had dropped 16%.
The loyalty to the product is they're
pulling that card out.
And that was one, and that was one that we
tracked and
talked about to the organization on a
consistent basis.
And there were frankly some people
concerns, saying Ken,
if we give some of this out, what if we
don't achieve it.
So that's part of the reality,
then we're gonna have to come up with
strategies to ensure.
That we can get people to pull their card
out of their wallet more.
Second thing we looked at is we said, will
people trade down because as
you saw with a lot of retailers, people
were trading down.
Our high price centurion products which in
fact when you first get a card,
you have to pay a 5000 dollar fee, and
then a 25 dollar fee every year.
The affluent sec, segment was hit hard,
and we said, can we hold on to that?
Well, one [UNKNOWN] we were pleased about,
but
we held that out as a metric, is that
people kept their cards.
They did not trade down.
And so, so our, our retention levels,
really stayed, in very, very good shape.
Third area, which was an important one
again, stay liquid.
Is it was at certain points in time,
an absolutely horrifying experience when
the markets froze up.
And people were very concerned about
funding.
So what we said at this point was that we
in fact having.
Limited to no experience in the deposit
gathering business,
that we actually were going to focus on
gathering deposits,
cuz we were rel, very reliant on the
wholesale funding model.
>> Hm.
>> This is where I think a brand is very
important, and fortunately the service.
Ethic that the dean talked about, the
reputation and
the trust that was developed was helpful
to us, but
we put together a very innovative strategy
and from a standing start in 12
months we in fact had gathered over 26
billion dollars in deposits.
Taking care of our funding needs.
That in fact helped the organization a
great deal.
Then because of the uncertainty of the
environment,
not because we thought we were gonna go
out of business, but
frankly I said as an insurance policy,
should we do TARP?
And we went back and forth with that.
And we ended up taking close to three
billion dollars of Tarp money
which by the way we were.
We were one of the first companies to
repay at a 26% return for the U.S.
taxpayer which I feel very good about.
I also remind people when they talk about
Tarp is I
said I say I don't know about your
investment portfolio.
But I don't think you got a 26% return
[LAUGH] on your investment portfolio.
So the, the important point there was to
take some contingencies out, and
to explain to people the reasons why.
And then, in fact, we.
Identified areas for investment, so I
think the balances, you've gotta demon,
demonstrate the strategies, but then you
have to set some markers that you
can let people know about the progress on
a very regular basis.
>> As you deliver those messages, how do
you get those messages out to the broader
organization, and then what are some tools
or tactics you use to actually pulse your
organization so you're, you're not
isolated in the executive suite?
>> Well, it's a good ,.
We, we do a lot of, pulsing through the
organ, organization.
There's obviously a lot of informal
feedback, but what we have done,
increasingly, is to rely online.
On, on getting that feedback, because the
terrific thing is you can.
Get questions out very quickly.
We're an organization that knows how to
analyze information and
data, that's one of our strengths.
And so to be able to correlate, some of
the drivers of satisfaction,
where people are confused on an issue, is
absolutely critical.
We have town halls via satellite.
Because I think you want to have a notion
that we are one company
and doing these global town halls have
been very important.
I do also as well as a number of our
senior leaders.
It's what I call brown bag lunches.
With approximately thirty employees.
Where I give them first sort of a three
minute here's my temperature.
Here's how I feel about the business.
Then ask me anything you want.
And then I say to them always at the end
of the lunch.
Only have one favor.
Is I would like you to communicate to five
to ten people.
And give them your impression.
And you can say, I think Ken is a jerk.
I don't know what he was talking about.
It's better that they hear it from you.
Then they just imagine it.
It would be preferable I don't say that to
them.
They are more positive.
[LAUGH].
and, and those have gone, those have gone
very well.
But, I think, basically, in the world we
live in today just like marketing
every single channel, you should be using.
face-to-face, online, every single
channel.
Speaker: I've read, one of the things you,
you encourage with an AMEX is this idea of
constructive confrontation.
Speaker: Right.
Speaker: I'm just wondering what it
means for you, and if there are any costs
associated with that.
Speaker: Yeah.
Here's, here's what's important.
And I think, you know, it's critical.
What you're trying to develop in any
organization, is a level of transparency.
And openness and honesty.
And what I find in most organizations
that,
where things get bogged down, is when
people feel that they have to
game the system in some way to get a point
across.
The amount of time you waste, the chances
for, misalignment.
Of, priorities, is a real problem.
And, so what, what I try to do.
Is to make sure that I leverage
the information that we have about the
organization.
That people clearly understand what our
priorities are.
And I think that works very well.
>> Switching gears a little bit,
you've been at American Express since
1981, which I find incredible just
given the world I see today at least where
employees switch companies a lot.
What has kept you at AMEX over all these
years?
And how has your leadership style evolved
over the years to where it is today?
>> You know, I think what has kept me at
the company, and I'll
give you just a little bit of background,
in a sense is I, I went to law school.
Thinking that I would probably practice
for two or
three years and then I really wanted to go
into venture capital.
And this is really going to date me,
but when I was coming out cable was really
the big deal.
[LAUGH] That was going to change the
world.
[LAUGH]
>> And so, Amex had entered into a joint
venture with Warner Amex,
and at the time, Lou Gerstner was running,
one of the major parts of the company,
and, Lou had heard about me from a client
that, he knew.
And I talked to him about joining the
planning department in
a relatively junior role.
But I said I really want to work on cable.
And he said we'll see if we can make that
happen.
And I've told this tory in the past and so
Louis heard me say this.
It never happened.
[LAUGH] but, but it didn't happen for some
very good reasons.
And one of the things that was a
particularly important
point that Lou made to me was that, that
AmEx was a company
that was a service company, but was a very
idea-driven.
Company.
And that you could, in fact, see your
ideas implemented in
a relatively short period of time, and you
could impact people's lives.
And for me that was one of the important
things that I
believe in business is I wanna make a
difference in people's lives.
I like being in the service business.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But I also like the intellectual
challenge that you can come up with ideas,
and you can make things happen.
And so, this is a company that continues
to evolve in some very major ways.
And is a dramatically different company,
because when I joined the company in
1981 it was on the verge of actually
becoming a financial supermarket.
We had Lehman, we had Shearson, if we had
all those companies today,
I would not be talking to you.
[LAUGH].
>> It would be a very different
environment.
So I think ideas, things that has kept me
there, ideas make a big difference.
The service commitment that people have is
incredible, and
I often say where the company has made
strategic mistakes.
What has protected the company has been
our
front line people cuz they really have
built the reputation of the company.
>> A number of CEOs who've spoken here in
the past have remarked that reflection and
introspection and setting aside time and
space to think and
generate ideas is important.
And it has been important to their
leadership style.
Just wondering how you feel about that and
what are things that you do to kind of set
that time and space for yourself?
>> Yeah, I, you know, I think what is
important and what's critical is to make
sure that you are exposing yourself to a
range of ideas.
So you had talked about constructive
confrontation.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is I think I didn't answer as
directly as I could, and
this will, will actually be helpful there.
I think what is important and why
constructive confrontation is so
important, and why it opens up ideas,
is because the status quo has to be
constantly challenged.
And what you want is an environment,
what I want is an environment where people
really feel passionate.
And if you feel passionate about things,
you should debate them, and
you should care about them, and
you should challenge each other and that
makes for an incredibly vital environment.
So, I will sometimes instigate debate
intentionally.
And go in and frankly, take a position and
a point of view that I know will screw
things up.
Now you got to be careful, because when
you're CEO, they'll go, what, wow!
[LAUGH] You know, what's the deal?
So you have to be careful in doing that.
But, what is critical is there are a lot
of
terrific ideas at every level of a
company.
And so you wanna set up the mechanisms
again, through every channel to do that.
But the tone has to be set at the top that
you, in fact,
are the type of person that people feel
comfortable arguing with you on issues.
I always then make the point, however,
that once we decide on a course of action,
we can't then have people continuing to
debate, we gotta move forward.
Then the other thing I try to do is to
reach outside the company,
and and I put together I think a pretty
worldwide network
of people that I check in with a fair
amount online.
Some of it on the phone, some of it in
person.
That really bring out some different
perspectives.
So, it may not be that they give you the
brilliant idea, but they give you
a different way of thinking an issue that
helps you come up with that idea.
>> Sure.
I've, based on other places where you've
spoken,
you commented that mentoring is important
to you.
And I was just wondering if you'd speak to
who, who've been some of
your mentors along the way, and who
inspires you as a leader today?
>> Good.
I'll, I'll, talk about two or three
mentors that I'll have and then the other
point I'll make about mentoring, cuz I
think it's sometimes is misunderstood.
What I really believe is that if you wanna
develop,
to develop a true mentor relationship.
And you wanna network, you wanna network
off of your performance.
Just in fact, to meet someone is generally
not
that helpful because, here's sorta how the
trade works, at least for me.
Is if I'm gonna take on a mentee, and I
really do like to help people and
work with people and develop.
I think it's one of the most satisfying
parts of leadership.
I wanna get something in return.
I wanna be stimulated by the ideas that
they can come up with in the dialogue.
I want in fact, for them to have the
commitment,
that they're gonna really improve in the
areas that they need to improve on and
that they're capable of really making
things happen.
that's, that's, that's part of the trade
off.
And I think when you look at a mentor at
different levels,
sometimes you're looking for someone who
can give you technical advice.
That's not a mentor, to me.
>> Right.
>> That's an expert and that's very
important to seek out that expert advice.
What I look for in mentors, is really,
judgement.
because, that, to me, at the end of the
day,
from a leadership standpoint, is, is, is
really the toughest challenge.
and, so, over the years, I've had a
diversity of mentors.
And I'll talk about them in two
categories.
One is there's the obvious senior mentor.
And a few of the people that I would put
in that category for me is Warren Buffet.
Is a mentor I've been fortunate that he is
our largest investor.
But we've also developed a very good
professional and personal relationship.
What I know with Warren is that
performance matters, a big deal.
[LAUGH] He's a very nice man,
but do not think at all that performance
is not what it's about.
But, but what is most impressive with
Warren for
me is this combination of his intellect
and his values.
And how he approaches an issue and how he
has a criteria
that really is one of balanced of someone
who wants to
be incredibly successful, do very well in
his investments.
But at the same time, he really wants to
do the right thing.
And how he approaches issues have been
impressive.
Early on in my career, Lou Gersner was, a
very important mentor to me.
Hard driving, rigorous.
Objective and I really learned a lot from
him.
And Harvey Gollum was someone who
had the ability to analyze issues and.
Really drive down through the details, and
never assume because someone was telling
him a view, one of Harvey's favorite,
comments was always, is that a fact, or is
that your perspective?
And that just is a useful discipline, cuz
sometimes people get the two confused.
So I've really tried to pick different
qualities from the mentors.
The other part of mentorship is, that is
important though is, I've had a lot of
mentors in a structural sense that have
been at lower levels in the company.
And and I also make this point that what
you get with a,
a mentor that's a lower level, is at a
lower level in a company is an unfiltered
perspective in the sense that they'll tell
you who the phonies are, in the company.
And really is amazing, cuz they've been
there,
cuz people take liberties with people that
they don't think are senior, and and
I really have developed relationships with
people, cuz again,
remember my criteria for a mentor is
advice and judgement.
And there are people at lower levels who
have incredible judgement and
incredible insight.
That, coming up through the company helped
me tremendously to say you know,
at the end of the day, here are some
people you should stay away from,
because you can't trust them, for these
reasons.
Seen them in these situations or watch out
for these situation.
Or you may be approaching an issue in this
way.
Here's another way to think about it.
And so, I really encourage people
to develop mentors at different levels of
the organization.
>> Great.
Before we open it up to the audience.
>> Yeah.
>> I actually had a personal question,
if you don't mind.
Unemployed MBA student, I was wondering if
you'd help me qualify for
the centurion guard?
[LAUGH].
>> My shameless ask.
[LAUGH]
>> I can, I can help.
[LAUGH] But
unless you meet the criteria, I don't
think I'm gonna have much of an impact.
[LAUGH] but, I can advise you on how you
can perform
to certainly receive [LAUGH] [UNKNOWN]
>> I'll take you up on that.
>> Yes.
[APPLAUSE].
With that we'd love to open it up,
I believe there are mics along, or they're
already planted.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Mr Schnell, thank you for your.
>> Son.
>> Thank you for your speech just had
a quick question about Amex is undoubtedly
known as kind of the flag bearer within
the financial services industry when it
comes to card member satisfaction and,
and premier customer servicing, so my
question is kind of.
Moving forward when it comes to this,
this, premier servicing and
satisfaction what are your thoughts on
sorta of the next wave and
what is, what is AMEX doing to kinda get
ahead of the curve?
Is the you know, traditional centurion
platinum style of servicing going
to be relevant to sorta the next wave of
high net worth individuals and
how do you get ahead of that curve?
>> Yeah, here's what's important,
important, ,.
as, as you look at our company cuz we have
been
traditionally identified with what we call
the issuing business.
That we issue a range of cards.
The reality is that service is important
in every area,
but what you have to do is segment that
value proposition of service in,
in a very customized way.
And that's what we are doing.
However whenever you look at our company,
and
I'll talk about just a few of the areas
that I think are very exciting going
forward, we are more than just a payments
company.
If you said, can what really is your
company about?
What we do is we facilitate value to a
range of segments
using the payments vehicle, but what we're
not is a commodity payments company,
so I'll just give you a few examples that
will illustrate this point.
One is if you look at the payments
landscape, and you say, who's on,
who's in the issuing business, we are in
the issuing business.
In terms of billings,
we're the largest issuer in the world $620
billion in billings last year.
However, we also are a network processor
similar to Visa and
MasterCard, and we're a global network
processor.
But our card member, which helps our value
proposition with merchants,
spends three to four times the size of
average spend of Visa and MasterCard.
The third piece that we're on is that we
actually acquire merchants which Visa and
MasterCard don't.
Fourth piece is in rewards and
loyalty, we are actually one of the
largest loyalty companies in the world.
Now, the fact that we have information,
unlike any other person in payments,
company in payments, we have information
and
data on the issuing side of the business.
And we have information and data on the
merchant side of the business.
Information, as we all know, is power.
So as we go forward, and this is some of
the things that we are doing now,
is one, business to business represents a
tremendous opportunity.
And we're one of the leading payment
companies in business to business.
But the value proposition we're offering
companies is,
we're just not saying we're going to
facilitate your transaction.
We're saying to them,
we actually can help you reduce your
expenses using our products and services.
And so we have entered ventures which
concur in a range of companies.
Because if part of what we can do, is
facilitate that value to drive it.
We think that presents substantial
opportunity.
Emerging payments, we made an acquisition
of a company called Revolution Money.
That is, has some similar capabilities to
PayPal.
Because I believe person to person is
gonna be important,
I believe mobile is gonna be very
important.
We are doing a deal right now with ICBC,
the largest bank in China, and
UNPay, the largest mobile provider, where
we have a mobile payments capability.
But what we're increasingly doing is using
our information management capabilities-
To drive additional value for our
customers.
So a few things that might surprise you,
Darden Restaurants is one of the largest
restaurant chains in the country.
They rely heavily on our data to cite
their,
their restaurants that they're gonna put
up.
Why?
Because we have a range of data of
spending, which we aggregate.
We don't violate privacy laws, but we're
using that information.
They, they pay us a monthly fee.
That is a very attractive area, we're
doing that for more and more companies.
We have a deal with AT&T Wireless because
our customers travel all over the world,
so you connect the modeling with that with
roaming opportunities, and that's major.
If you go on the Delta Airlines site now,
for their loyalty program,
the company that is managing the site, the
marketing and the merchandising, is us.
Now, the important part of that, from a
virtual circle standpoint, is that
we in fact, believe that the opportunity
with our information to connect online and
offline is tremendous, because we not only
know habits and preferences and
sites where people go, but we actually
know if the transaction was consummated.
So emerging payments and alternative
payments is gonna be important for
us because we now have what I call
horizontal scale across the payments
landscape that is gonna help us drive that
business.
So what I see for us, is that increasingly
you're gonna see a melding of what we're
doing and what I call the broad category
of servicing, in a range of businesses,
that will help facilitate value for a
number of online and offline companies.
And we're going to leverage and optimize
the data we have more and the and
the partnerships, and our customer
connections more than ever.
However, the hallmark has to be, that I
believe particularly
in the uncertain environment that we're
in, and you look at the importance of
reputation, is that trust is gonna be even
more important, and
we know it's even gonna be more important
online, and that's where service comes in.
>> Thank you for sharing your time with us
today.
You've remarked that leadership need to be
consistently worked on in
order to attain the followership needed to
be successful.
You cited at the time improving your
listening skills.
What are you working on now, and what
would you say is the most important skill
for us to develop while at GSB in light of
the changing economy?
>> Here's, here's, here's what I would
say.
I think, first I'll go with, what are the
important skills, then I'll tell you
what I'm working on which is always a
range of things, and I really do believe,
if you wanna be a strong leader, you gotta
constantly work on areas.
I think that, what is absolutely critical
for
a leader today is the ability to connect
the dots.
You can't remain alone in your discipline.
What you gotta understand is how thing
interrelate.
What are the connections, and
then what are the relevant value drivers
for your business?
So the ability to in fact take in a broad
set of facts and knowledge,
and to see what the connection is to your
particular business is critical.
And so that means at the end of the day,
awareness of what is
going on in the world and trends, and
constantly saying,
what does this development mean for my
business and my customer?
Because at the end of the day, if you
wanna be a market leader and
innovate, you actually have to come to
conclusions that most people don't.
And most people don't because they take a
conventional view
of what they're working on.
So that ability to connect is critical.
For me what I'm particularly focused
on now is the BRIC countries.
And part of what I'm doing from a
development standpoint is while I'm
learning a lot about the business issues,
I'm actually spending a fair amount of
time through history books, trying to
understand some of the culture and
the psychology in the markets that we're
operating in, because I think
that it is easier to have a view of some
of the technical issues,
but if you want the type of emotional
engagement.
And one of the things that I think is
critical in the marketing of
products is this balance be, between
rational value and emotional connection.
And if in fact people really believe that
I understand who you are, and
I actually respect how you think, and that
can make an incredible difference.
So that's one of the areas that I'm
working on.
>> Yeah thank you very much for your talk.
My name is Kristoff Freezee.
I'm an MBA one.
You draw this picture of the great
investor you'll have who wants to do well,
and at the same time, right.
Can you, from your point of view, give us,
or
elaborate on, how do you define you are
doing right?
You are in an, in an industry where trust
is important.
You mentioned the data and sensitive data
you have, and where as the CEO,
you actually draw the line in your
company, and be this person that says,
we can't do this because it's not right.
>> Yeah, I, I think one of the most
critical responsibilities of
the CEO is to understand how to draw that
line and when to draw that line.
And, very frankly, it's very easy to
articulate in a broad way that you are a
principled person.
Where the rubber meets the road is how did
you act?
So I'll give you a few examples.
Five years ago, we did a competitive
analysis in the card business, and
we said, what are all the drivers of
revenue that our competitors are using?
And what we found was that there was a
substantial reliance on back end fees,
and a range of practices that,
frankly, would have generated a
substantial amount of money.
And I'm being circumspect here but it was
very, very substantial.
And and most of our competitors were in
fact, engaged in some
of those practices and many were engaged
in, in most of them.
We actually were very clear that we could
dramatically, even more, improve
the financial performance of the company,
but, we said, we don't think that's right.
And we said, and I said I don't think it's
right for
the following reasons, is I developed when
I was running our card businesses,
what we used in the company, we have three
operating principles.
One is provide superior value for the
customers and
clients that we choose to serve.
Second, do it in a way that allows us to
achieve best in class economics,
and every thing we do must support the
brand.
Then we have a set of values for the
company.
What was clear is, that one, we felt that
those practices were not consistent, and
we articulated that to the team of why we
were not going to pursue it.
We went through in general, and we went
through one by one.
And we said this is, this is the trade
off.
This is what we stand for as a company.
And there are a number of examples where
you're faced with a situation
where you know one, and these are the
toughest issues.
It's legal.
It's really not a problem, I mean so the
ethical, legal issues,
I mean if you're gonna do something that's
wrong, you got a problem.
But we have a situation where it's not,
it's perfectly legal.
Everyone's doing it.
Why not?
And the question is, what is the
commitment?
We were in a situation just this year.
Every major financial services company
basically decided that
they would cut their dividend.
And, and we talked about it,
and every, every banker that would come
in, investment banker, would say, Ken,
everyone's doing it, there's really not
any pressure.
And I said, look, you gotta understand,
with our company, we really have this
concept of promises to keep, and unless I
thought
that the company was really going under, I
just don't think we should do that.
And that wasn't illegal.
It wasn't, wouldn't be anything wrong,
morally, if I did that, but
the question is, what were the values of
the company and
what's the commitment that you need to
make?
And I don't criticize another company for
cutting their dividend, but for
us, I didn't think that was the right
thing to do.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I'm wondering in your 30 years at
American Express what you think you've,
you did differently both early and
later in your career in terms of both
within your job, and
then within the, within the sphere of
doing things to sort of,
further longer-term objectives that that
resulted in you being CEO today.
>> You know, I think, and it's, I would
say it's more, it's been more that my
behavior has evolved rather than a radical
change, but I'll give you a few examples
that I think were helpful to me and what I
would caution with all advice,
you've gotta personalize it and you've
gotta customize it to your own situation.
One is what has always excited me is, I
always wanted to work with really bright
people who I thought had good values and
would allow me to do exciting things.
I never came to the company with the
intent that I would become CEO.
Really it was until two or three years
before I became president, I remember
Harvey saying to me, you know I think you
could run the company, it really was not,
not that I was naive, but that just was
not the objective for me.
And, and I think it's important that your
personal ambition does not overcome you.
So that allowed me to be independent, to
take risks and
help me develop a perspective that I
thought I was focused on.
Here are thing that are not only right for
the company, but here are things that I
wanna do.
Doing them in a, in a, in a team concept
so I'm not a lone ranger, but
at the same time not just focused on
myself.
The second is that I've always believed
that you should focus on,
what are some ideas that can really change
the status quo in the business?
And and one of my first jobs which was a
lot of fun for me,
it was a big risk, is we had a business
that sold merchandise through the mail.
Now if you think about what's happening in
the online world: segmentation,
information analysis, and whatever, this
was terrific preparation.
But it was losing money,
and no one who was regarded as high
potential wanted to go into that business.
I actually thought that that channel was
exciting, and again, at that time,
since I didn't believe I was gonna be at a
big company for a long time, I said
this would be a great entrepreneurial
experience when I run my own business.
So, let me get in and learn about this
direct marketing channel,
because they sell a wide variety of
products, but we came up with some
very innovative ideas in how to
merchandise, and in a two or
three year period, we went from 100
million to 800 million in sales.
And we developed some sourcing strategies.
We went over to Asia and Japan and we had
a deal that I was able to work out with
some of the top manufacturers, that they
would let us have a new product for 90 to
120 days and we'd sort of tested for them,
and then they could go retail with it.
And that worked out great for us, and
helped us get some
decent margins because in that business
you're always pressed on the margin side.
I also was very involved in the
development
of our loyalty program, and saw the power
of
what that could do, and, and rewards has
made a major difference for the company.
So I, I like strategy a lot but I also
like to implement, but
what's most important is I really like
changing the paradigm and
I think that helped me tremendously.
The third and I hesitate even saying this
because this can be self serving,
but I think if you really wanna build
leadership,
what's most important at the end of the
day, and the first thing I look for.
And try to analyze with people is
integrity.
And in my definition of integrity it's not
just being honest,
it's what's the consistency of words and
actions.
And over time what people saw in the
organization certainly is
not that I was perfect.
Because as I said, I would have strong
views if I thought sometimes at meetings,
I've gotten better that their comments
were not particularly insightful.
I would not necessarily listen carefully
to those
comments I had been told I've improved a
lot.
[LAUGH] in that area over time and I, and
I think I have.
But what I did develop a reputation for
in the company, was a consistency of words
and actions.
And that helped me to develop a
followership and
get the emotional engagement that you need
as a leader.
>> Hi is this, [SOUND] okay, the concept
of
constructive conflict really stuck out to
me and
from the outside you can see the value of
conflict in
situations but when you're actually
inside.
And you're hearing negative ideas or
embracing that conflict,
it can be really uncomfortable, and people
can get quite defensive.
So I was just wondering how you have been
able to turn those negative thoughts and
emotions into a positive aspect for
the company and use it to really motivate
performance.
Yeah, here's, and let me very clear, is
this is a ongoing effort in the company.
And I would certainly not put us yet at
the level that I'd like to be at,
cuz to your point, it is that hardest
thing to make happen.
We're a company that I think is very
driven for results.
But what we have always not done
historically and
we've improved a lot in this, is to
confront each other.
So what I say in AmEx speak, and I use
this often in the organization, that we,
when we started off on this around ten
years ago, is I
would say when you hear someone say at
AmEx, I don't mean to disagree with you.
What they're really saying is, I totally
disagree with you.
[LAUGH] I will annihilate you.
[LAUGH] I will do everything in my power
to make sure this doesn't happen.
So, that was extreme, but the reality is
that the sort of,
behavior rules that were set up is I want
open and constructive confrontation.
Here's what that means.
You've got something to say, say it at the
meeting.
And if it's outside the meeting and so,
the first few times when
we put this in more than a few times,
you'd have sort of the usual
behavior of people would have the meeting,
they'd go through issues, circle back.
Ken, let me tell you, I really have a
concern with what so and so said.
And I said, excuse me, let's call up so
and so, no, no, no, don't do it.
We're gonna call them up.
So and so, come in the office.
So and so said.
[LAUGH] Well, why didn't you say at the
meeting?
And then I said, look,
now let's respect each other, so what I
don't want when we disagree.
That you necessarily say I think you're a
jerk.
What you can say is look, I disagree with
the idea, but
personal respect is critical.
But don't hesitate to be very direct in
saying why you have the issue, how
you're thinking about the issue, because
that's gonna bring out better ideas.
And it is uncomfortable but I will tell
you, in every single area
one of the most difficult things to
accomplish is the transition of CEOs.
One is I did with Harvey, which was great
from a constructive confrontation.
I said Harvey, let's take two day, and
let's go through a set of issues.
What is it in the transition you're gonna
do.
What am I gonna do?
What do we agree on, what do we not?
And sometimes those sessions get heated.
Sometimes, but the end of the day was done
with really very strong
personal directness and
the behaviour was very well done.
So I think you can be direct, I think you
can be honest.
I think you can raise your voice.
And part of the counseling I give to
people as they go through is.
Sometimes, you may wanna telegraph, and
I'll say to someone, you know, I'm gonna,
I really feel strongly about this, so I am
gonna argue in a very vociferous way.
[LAUGH] Don't take it personally, but
understand, this is something that is
really meaningful.
And so what I what I don't want to leave
you with the impression with is that
constructive confrontation is taking place
everywhere and is at the level but
is something that I am relentless about in
the organization because you,
you waste so much time.
I mean, if we're, everything is moving so
fast paced in this world, that if you
had people saying, another phrase we used
to use is, let's take this offline.
What do you mean take it offline?
[LAUGH] We're right here.
Take it offline?
Let's talk about it right here.
So it's, it's, it's very very important.
The more you can get people engaged.
And talking through the issues.
What it actually says is that I respect
you and your ideas, and the fact that
you are impassioned about those ideas, and
you're willing to take some risk.
Because that's what it takes in business
is, you gotta put some risk out there.
If you're gonna be careful, then we're not
gonna move forward as a company,
we're not gonna be a leader.
>> Last question.
>> Hi, my name Regina Cross and I'm an MBA
one.
I had a question with respect to some of
the learning that you
have with the BRIC countries.
You mentioned that you're focused on the
traditions and culture and history.
And just wondered, kind of, maybe, what
the top one or
two things are that you have learned so
far with your research.
And how you are working within your
organization to meet the needs.
And the, the, the variances within the
culture in order to meet their needs?
>> Here's two or three, and some of these
are pretty basic, but, there
is a strong view, that the U.S. looks down
on everyone, and can be patronizing.
And the issue that I think is important,
and one of the things that I learned is,
in fact, if you're meeting someone and
people really believe,
and you tell them I actually read a book
about your country.
I read some history about it, and I took a
step back, I found and
say, wow that's pretty unusual [LAUGH].
I mean, really, it's, it's I just came
back from a week trip in the in
the the Mideast and went to a number of
countries.
And I wasn't able to read up on every one.
But whether it was a dinner meeting or
lunch meeting letting someone
know that I knew something about the
politics of the country, I knew something
about the economic environment, I may have
known a particular history point.
Lets people know, just as you're forming,
some type of personal engagement, that you
take them seriously.
And that you think that their country is
important and they even learn something.
And so the biggest loaning in a sense to
me is, just as you would any
business problem, to go into a country,
and you're running off the plane and
you might say to someone, look, brief me
about a few things that are happening
here, is not exactly gonna endear you to
the people that you meet with
cause they're going to say it's all
superficial, we know they're about.
This is the deal, but if they say, boy
this person actually took time.
and, and there's no problem admitting
that, look I'm a neofight,
I don't have, I've only been to the
country once, or twice, or whatever.
But to show real engagement, and.
Remember giving some feedback to one of
our people where we went into a market and
the person wanted to take
him to a place that he thought was very
special in his country.
The person has said I think I'll go back
to the hotel it's been a long trip,
little bit tired, I don't think that helps
[LAUGH] build the type of
relationship and engagement that you want.
>> Thank you very much.
Really appreciated.
>> Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [BLANK_AUDIO]